hey everyone its Peter Brown standing in
for Michael Hardy for his review in
progress of overwatch at first glance
overwatch is a simple team shooter two
groups of six taken from a cast of
twenty-one multifarious heroes vie for
control and momentum in four standard
game modes as the hours go by though
overwatch on peels new layers not just
in how matches unfold but in how
different characters interact how small
actions contribute to the bigger picture
and how many ways there are to play the
process of discovery doesn't appear to
stop even after 50 hours I'm still
learning overwatch as intricacies the
overwatch seems to be a simple team
shooter at first glance play it long
enough and it grows into a seminal
shooter
overwatch is somewhat of a time machine
traveling back through the history of
the shooter genre and borrowing ideas
from iconic shooters throughout the
years the fluid arena combat of quake
the cutthroat precision of Counter
Strike the dynamism of titanfall and the
reflexive firefights of Call of Duty
but overwatch isn't a slave to its
influences it refines them into
something more by standing on the
shoulders of giants overwatch has
crafted a fresh modern complex
experience that displays a confidence in
its various elements and how they all
flow together this ever-changing
experience hinges on the quality of its
colorful cast and in this respect
overwatch has delivered with every hero
Ginji darts over walls and past enemy
defenses whipping ninja stars and
slicing through defense turrets with his
sword fara flies over the fray raining
Rockets down on key control points and
hulking tank characters these are
characters that could have entire games
designed around them an overwatch brings
them together in one place what's
amazing is that despite how different
each hero is they clash interact and
cooperate in compelling matches there's
always some way you can contribute
whether it's covering your team with
reinhardt's massive shield or disrupting
the enemy offensive his tracer fitting
in and out through time and space
pestering opponents before you warp into
the next room and away from the skirmish
over watches social mechanics encourage
teamwork a post-match a voting period
lets you choose MVPs based on factors
overlooked in other shooters such as the
amount of hit points healer mercy
replenished the number of energy
barriers area projected on teammates
where the time lucio spent buffing his
cohorts movement speed over watches map
design amplifies the refinement and
variety of its colorful cast there are
crucial choke points and varying sight
lines throughout the Foundry's of all
sky industries create tight corridors
and vital elevated positions
overwatch combines the intricacies of
its environment with the complexities of
its powerful cast it finds balance and
what could have easily been chaos
but over watch the strongest aspect is
how it manages to constantly teach you
something new each match reveals another
detail you might have previously ignored
the audio cue that signals macri's
lethal Deadeye attack the sound a
stalwart Bastion makes when entering
it's dangerous turret form playing
overwatch is a digging process and
finding new layers is part of what makes
it special it's not impressive that
overwatch tries so many different things
it's outstanding that it succeeds in
every attempt from the dozens of hours
I've played in overwatch as beta it's
clear that developer Blizzard has
crafted a fantastic shooter worthy of
praise on numerous levels it manages to
maintain focus
despite the complexities and variety of
its cast locales and the interlocking
systems however because overwatch is
servers only went live today we're
holding our final opinion until we've
tested the game on PC PlayStation 4 and
Xbox one in real-world conditions if all
goes well from a technical standpoint
overwatch stands to be one of the best
shooters in years
I'm unstoppable